[Musique]
comment ce mec est-il encore en vie ce n'est pas un
mec
neuro mec c'est un homme beau je suis
là nous sur le tournage d'Avengers j'ai eu la
chance avec d'autres gardiens
de la galaxie de rejoindre les
Avengers et d'être  ici et avoir l'
opportunité de sauver le monde est-ce que cela
fait de vous un Avenger maintenant aussi je ne sais pas
peut-être comme un Avenger de troisième chaîne
ouais parce que l'un des membres fondateurs
ouais merci donc il est parmi
toutes les personnes qui  J'ai eu la
chance de travailler avec ces deux
gars en particulier et le triumvirat que
nous avons formé ensemble,
c'est une amitié très spéciale et des décennies
d'horloges ensemble.
Lizzy a été vraiment vraiment géniale
et je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de très
puissant dans le fait de pouvoir jouer des femmes
qui font des choses rangées et ces femmes sont
tellement géniales que nous avons passé un très bon
moment à traîner avec tout le monde sur le
l'ensemble est l'une des meilleures parties de ce travail en
fait parce qu'il a ce genre
de grande famille élargie.
il
était ardu et ennuyeux et pas
particulièrement drôle bien au début Blanche
c'est difficile de savoir quoi faire un
Cumberbatch et puis plus je
passais de temps avec lui sur et hors plateau je me suis juste un
peu entiché de ce gars je
pensais que tu connaissais le voyage  que
Robert Downey jr.  est fait, il est le
parrain de tout cela, c'est littéralement
l'aventure d'une
vie.